c'est ce que j'ai déjà été pour les
verts mais maintenant je suis très
heureux d'être avec le npd
c'est le troisième transfusion lice dans
longueuil saint-hubert éric ferland ans
et chef du parti vert au québec et aussi
souverainiste je l'ait déjà été c'est
sûr ok mais pour moi l'important c'est
de travailler avec un grand pays pour
l'injustice sociale et les changements
climatiques
deux thèmes souvent repris par un autre
candidat qui le mois dernier important
fait le chemin inverse du npd vers les
verts nouvelles couleurs donc pour
pierre nantel après huit ans passés à
ottawa comme député néo-démocrate jeu
comptera que les gens peuvent dire à
baillargues et il a demandé à face à des
oblats gasoil et au vert mais la vérité
c'est je suis très constate vous
demander à des gens malgré cette spar
ils vont vous dire que ça fait belle
lurette que je parle d'environnement
il est toujours souverainiste mais pour
lui la question nationale vielles après
la planète être rii lui sera un défi et
il le sait ici le parti vert n'a eu que
deux et demi pour cent des votes en 2015
j'invite les gens peu importe la couleur
politique à devenir vert pour cette
élection aussi au québec parce que je
pense que le québec peut jouer un grand
rôle dans la création ne se pas tant ces
cabinets climatiseurs troisième
transfuge réjean hébert candidat vedette
pour justin trudeau
il y a cinq ans et pourtant avec pauline
marois qu'il célébrait il était son
ministre de la santé il était
souverainiste c'est du passé
fédéraliste mais j'aime pas cette jambe
de dichotomie je pense qu'on est passé à
des grands enjeux de société les
changements climatiques
l'égalité sociale réjean hébert figure
même dans la vidéo de la fameuse chanson
du parti libéral
comme quoi on mise sur lui les libéraux
en 2015 ont terminé à seulement 700 voix
de pierre nantel et à longueuil
saint-hubert est un député dans le parti
au pouvoir pour être capable de défendre
de pousser les dossiers de transports en
commun les dossiers de logement elle est
ce que ça vous dérange quelqu'un qui
change de parti non non je pensais juste
qu'il faut qu'ils changent pas d'idée
j'ai un petit peu même si leurs actions
parce que mon île cantiran quand tu fais
afin qu'elle participe à ce que tu une
idée d une idéologie qui est le data
thaï tô t fête du rugby d'être un sujet
tout ce que vous voulez et dans cette
course pas comme les autres un quatrième
candidat est très optimiste celui du
bloc
je regardais la mise adversaires en ce
moment pesci trade qui continue comme ça
à s'interroger sur des affaires moi je
parle au monde
je parle de lui un jeu pas des vrais à
frêche fait du porte à porte
denis trudel avait fini troisième à
moins de 4% de pierre nantel et du npd
en 2015
il cogne sur le cloud nationaliste dans
cette ville plutôt bleue qui a déjà élu
au provincial
rené lévesque et pauline marois bloc on
est dans cet élan à loger dire les gens
se reconnaissent la dernière grande en
plus nationaliste à québec les gens sont
enchaînés dans le rouge à leurs chants
beaucoup
le candidat conservateur et patrick
clown son parti avait fini loin derrière
il y a quatre ans aux électeurs de
longueuil de se faire une tête adapté
pas d'idée fixe sa balade sa valeur
comment je vois ça je trouve ça
difficile parce que c'est un petit peu
mais elle est la compagne sur le terrain
sera importante ici jean-sébastien
cloutier radio canada longueuil